and it's it's definitely real we're
we're living in this reality that is
underwritten by these extraterrestrials
they're not just here to hang out
they're actually paying attention to us
they're essentially what we could think
of as Angelic beings there are also some
very bad ones a colonel who was read
into this much more secret level of the
universe he was shown a 3-in thick
binder that described 57 different
varieties of extraterrestrials that are
visiting Earth right now they
predominantly look human but they're not
as different looking as you would think
as far as I know there's only ever maybe
10 or 20,000 of these humans on Earth at
any one time these reptilians look
humanlike but they are extremely
frightening in appearance but when they
open up that mouth it's it's it's
hideous sharp teeth and they are they
have vertical sliit pupils their eyes
will either be like yellow or orange or
red so they're scary
looking